Somewhere, caught between parallel dimensions,
is the containment breach to end all containment
breaches.
Countless unnumbered and nameless anomalies
on a warpath to destroy what has become of
a now-unrepentantly evil Foundation.
A testing site rendered distorted and unstable
under the power of countless reality-warping
objects, and me caught in the middle of it.
You’re probably wondering how I got here.
Well, for starters, I’m what is known as
an anomaly.
If I can see something, I can crush it, using
my brain.
I guess you’d say I have a form of telekinesis,
but fine control or remote levitation are
not my forte.
I’m not sure who I was before the GOC apprehended
and brought me here to this strange place.
A place ruled by a cruel man named Eliott
Emerson and the even crueler Foundation that
he directed.
A place called Site-13, and as for the rest
of us contained here, we don’t get numbers.
The only name I have is the one I gave myself.
If I'm destined to be trapped in this infernal
place by a man named Emerson, I may as well
self-identify as his equal and opposite.
You can call me Thoreau, and this is the story
of how I managed to survive 100 days in Site-13…
well, after everything went haywire.
Here goes nothing…
Day 1.
Like I said before, this all began with the
containment breach to end all containment
breaches.
It is chaos in the hallways, with anomalies
running rampant everywhere.
Most are taking revenge on the guards and
researchers, but not every one of the unnumbered
is in solidarity.
The crystal butterflies and the memetic scribe
are indiscriminately going after anything
that isn’t them, including each other.
As for me, I’m wearing a specialized helmet
that keeps me blindfolded.
It’s a power suppressant, since my anomalous
ability only works on things I can see clearly.
I’d love to remove it, but there’s no
way to find out which guard has clearance
to deactivate my headgear when things are
this manic.
As much as I’d love to celebrate the reckoning
of Site-13, I decided it was better to stay
inside my cell for the day.
Let the record show that if The Foundation
or the GOC do crack down on this, I was well-behaved
during the breach.
Day 2.
It’s gotten marginally quieter out there.
I don’t think the fighting has stopped as
much as it has moved out of the halls where
I’ve been contained.
The Foundation hasn’t dropped off any more
rations today, so I start to think that maybe
this really was the big one.
What if everyone somehow got out?
I started to wonder about some of my fellow
anomalous humanoids and if the containment
breach had given them a chance.
I don’t really know what they look like
because most of the time, I’m forced to
wear a blindfold to suppress my powers, but
I have been able to pick up a few hints through
listening.
There’s a clown named Bobble, he was already
here when I arrived.
And no, he’s not a guy dressed as a clown,
but like a genuine actual clown.
He’s nice enough, but I get the impression
he’d be a bad influence on kids if there
were any here.
Other than Elijah, of course.
He’s known as the Leech Boy since he can
drain the blood from people with his hands.
Scary stuff, really.
I don’t dislike either of them, but I’d
rather not take my chances running into them
during a containment breach.
I guess I'll wait this one out a bit longer.
I had water from the containment unit sink
if I needed to sate my thirst and a day without
a meal wasn’t exactly something new.
Day 3.
I felt a strange rumbling in the air this
morning, like everything in the entire universe
was picked up and dropped back down somewhere
else.
I don’t know how else to describe it.
I once heard some of the guards talking about
a reality-bending machine called the Thresher
on the lower levels.
Could it be the work of that thing?
Day 4.
My old friend Bobble The Clown actually came
through for me.
He has taken up residence in the digital interface
of my cell and is giving me details of what
is happening out there.
The funniest thing about this clown is that
he lives inside of electronic devices.
Bobble was never threatened by my abilities
because they only work on the physical world.
The most I could do to him is crush a television
set where he was dwelling.
Our friendship is based on the fact that the
two of us are among the only things in Site-13
that couldn’t cause harm to each other.
And sadly, I think that my list of enemies
is much higher than Bobble’s.
And a lot of the things out there might hold
a grudge.
The reason I haven’t been thrown into the
fire is that my matter compression ability
is useful to the Foundation.
I’m not proud to admit it, but I’ve agreed
multiple times to use my abilities to bring
some of my fellow anomalies, particularly
the larger ones, down a manageable size for
disposal.
My reward for this is that I’m not subject
to some of the more deadly experiments here,
though it's not like these evil, unethical
scientists can resist some light torture.
Did I mention how much these people hate anomalies?
Because make no mistake, they hate us a lot.
Bobble said he couldn’t stick around, but
that there was an untouched supply of rations
a few cells down that I – as an organism
that needs to eat to survive – should go
and find.
Even with the blindfold it shouldn’t be
too easy for me to get there.
I’ll think about going tomorrow.
Day 4.
As I felt my way through the hallway to the
other cell, I could tell that things had gone
really off the deep end.
There were people fused into the walls, no
doubt because of one of the other anomalies,
and I had no idea whether or not they were
on my side.
There was no doubt that memetic cognitohazards
were scrawled all over the surfaces of the
facility as well.
If The Scribe had truly been on the loose,
he’d definitely have made those brain-destroying
symbols he always did.
Maybe my current lack of vision was a good
thing.
Especially because spending so much of my
time blind had enhanced my sense of smell.
From the inside of a nearby open cell, I caught
wind of a tray of day-old Foundation rations.
And what luck, they were the same kind usually
given to humanoid anomalies like me.
These must have been the ones that Bobble
had mentioned.
I settled into this new cell and enjoyed my
first full meal in days.
Day 5
With the power-suppressing device still firmly
on my head, getting out of here seemed like
a pipe dream.
I spent the day thinking about the only other
person in Site-13 who was kind to me: Dr.
Hadley.
She was a researcher who took care of some
of the humanoid anomalies.
Even though she’s working with The Foundation,
I get the feeling that she’s actually a
really good person deep down.
Maybe it's the Stockholm Syndrome talking,
but I really wish I could see her face.
She always had sympathy for Elijah - the leech
boy - and saw him as an ordinary kid despite
his blood-draining powers.
I can only hope that both of them are safe.
Day 6.
I continued to make my way across the facility
hugging the wall as tightly as I could.
I could hear weapon fire throughout the facility
and countless anomalies battling it out.
All of a sudden, I was caught off guard when
I heard several footsteps coming towards me.
These must have been foundation personnel,
I thought.
A shot rang out, and I was hit directly in
my headgear by some kind of piercing round.
Fortunately, the suppression device was strong
enough to take the hit for me, so I didn’t
take direct damage, and it was equally fortunate
that being shot at had caused it to malfunction.
I could now remove the headgear and blindfold
and stare down the group of armed Foundation
guards in front of me.
“It’s The Crusher!”
One of them shouted.
“My name is Thoreau,” I responded.
I didn’t give them a chance to fire again,
and using my ability to defend myself was
the only way out.
After all the anomalies I had compressed at
their orders, doing the same to Emerson’s
forces came all too naturally.
To them, we were merely objects.
Things to be used up before we’re incinerated.
Whether we’re human, inhuman, or something
entirely indescribable: It makes no difference
to Emerson and his underlings, since all of
us are going to the same place.
After that encounter with the guards, I decided
that I wouldn’t use my powers to harm my
fellow anomaly.
We had all endured so much in Site-13 that
it felt needlessly brutal to let the one thing
that I had in common with the other prisoners
be a weapon against them.
I couldn’t guarantee that all of the other
anomalies would treat me the same way, but
the idea of living by that principle filled
me with a sense of purpose.
From now on, it was me against Site-13.
I would survive and escape to the outside
world.
Day 7.
To my surprise, there was a mundane vending
machine in this terrible place.
I used my powers to break into it: raking
in the delicious bounty of chips, protein
bars, and fruit snacks.
This stash would take care of my sustenance
needs for a while, so I stored them in a military
pack I had taken from one of the guards I
had fought with the other day.
Day 8.
I began to realize that the rooms I was traveling
through were repeating themselves.
It was hard to really notice at first, with
all the cognitohazards I was trying to avoid,
but it seemed like Site-13 was reshuffling
itself in a way that had made my progress
through it completely circuitous.
While this meant that my encounters with dangerous
anomalies and guards had been basically nonexistent,
it also meant that I wasn’t making any progress
towards escape.
Day 9-14.
Yup, I’m officially stuck in a loop now.
This was probably unavoidable even if I had
a mental map of the facility or even a physical
map.
Reality is so broken by the effects of the
Thresher that I don’t even know if the rest
of Site-13 even still exists.
I honestly wouldn’t be that upset if Director
Emerson and the rest of the Foundation personnel
had been flung into oblivion.
That would be worth it even if I spent the
rest of my days here wandering around and
eating vending machine food.
Day 15.
I gained access to a new area of the facility,
only to find that it was a stairwell filled
with a terrifying black gooey substance.
I had no idea what this stuff was, but perhaps
it was best not to touch it.
Yeah, that would definitely be for the best.
Still, there were stairs going away from the
goo which could lead me closer to an exit,
so I decided to take that risk and sprint
up to a higher level.
As if waiting for a cue, the liquid began
to rise as soon as I set foot in the stairwell.
I climbed the stairs as fast as I could, but
this stuff was determined.
I thought I could slow it down by crushing
some of the stairs, but using my powers caused
some of the substance to splash onto my hand.
It didn’t hurt, but now my hand had a hole
directly through the palm.
I could still feel everything, but the affected
area was now see-through.
Freaky, but it definitely could have been
worse.
I made out of the stairwell otherwise intact,
and thankfully the new floor I found myself
on wasn’t anywhere I had been before.
There were giant leeches everywhere, crawling
through cracks in the wall.
Did Elijah do this?
Day 16-27.
I continued making my way through the unexplored
sections, encountering a lot of the remains
of dead guards but no fellow anomalies besides
the leeches.
I made a point of not getting too close to
them, and they didn’t seem to bother me
either.
Most of the leeches seemed content to drink
the blood from the corpses of which there
were plenty.
There were fewer cognitohazards, and I was
grateful for that.
I managed to find and crush a few more vending
machines to restock my food supplies.
Compared to the rations I had been fed since
I was first brought here, these snacks practically
tasted like gourmet food.
On day 28.
Bobble found me again, or rather I found him.
He was inside of a laptop in one of the abandoned
research offices.
We compared notes, and it gave me some idea
of what happened that caused so many of us
to escape.
Apparently, Dr. Hadley had stood up to Emerson
and sabotaged the incinerator.
I guess she truly was a good person.
I’ll have to thank her personally if I happen
to find her still alive somewhere in all of
this.
It could have also been her who activated
the Thresher machine, but I wouldn’t put
it past Emerson to do the same.
Of course, he’d have done so in an effort
to take the rest of us with him.
Isn’t it remarkable that the people we think
we can trust and the people who hold us prisoner
might wind up taking the same action for completely
different reasons?
It could be that my embarrassing little crush
on Dr. Hadley was stopping me from seeing
the bigger picture.
In any case, I thanked Bobble and pressed
onward.
Day 29-39.
While the reshuffling of the hallways and
rooms has considerably slowed down my exploration
of Site-13, I can safely say that I’m making
progress towards finding some kind of way
out.
I’ve come to realize that the further I
get from the lower levels where the Thresher
is at its most powerful, the more stable the
facility’s layout becomes.
If I can make it to the rooftop, then I’m
as good as free.
So my guiding philosophy has become “onwards
and upwards.”
Day 40.
Now, this is unexpected!
I was confronted by another group of armed
Foundation personnel – different uniforms
- one of the Mobile Task Forces, I think – but
instead of shooting me, they just started
asking questions.
The most confusing of which was…
“What is your object class and SCP designation
number?”
I had no idea how to answer.
Were things that different in the other containment
sites?
Site-13 had never given us numbers or formal
classifications beyond simple nicknames derived
from our anomalous properties.
I wasn’t sure what was going on, but I also
didn’t want to risk getting put back into
containment.
I couldn’t be sure this wasn’t some kind
of foundation trick or I hadn’t somehow
lost my mind because of some cognitohazard
I’d accidentally glimpsed.
I crushed a doorway using my powers and ran
for it.
A few shots echoed behind me, but the apparent
leader of the mobile task force called for
them to hold their fire.
Whoever these people were, they definitely
weren’t with Emerson.
Day 41-52.
If the leeches, repeating staircases, and
occasional hostile anomalies weren’t enough,
now I have to deal with these alternative
Foundation personnel poking around here.
It was one thing to protect myself from Site-13’s
dedicated guards, since they’d been responsible
for holding me captive, but my conscience
was telling me not to attack these new mobile
task agents.
Instead, I hid from them as well as I could,
running to another area whenever I was discovered.
I can’t remember where I heard it from,
but I know there’s some old saying about
great power and great responsibility.
Point is, I didn’t want to have the responsibility
of having used my powers to hurt people who
didn’t deserve it.
Still, it seemed like many of the anomalies
didn’t feel the same way.
From what I observed during my circuitous
route around the facility, I could tell that
these mobile task force agents were suffering
losses.
Day 53.
On Day 53, I found a lone agent huddled in
a fetal position against the wall of one of
the containment corridors.
It seemed that no other members of their squad
were present, so either they had been separated
in the madness of Site-13, or they were the
sole survivor.
Either way, I felt sympathetic, so I approached
them in an effort to communicate.
What I learned during this conversation absolutely
blew my mind.
It turned out that the Thresher activation
had caused Site-13 to literally jump universes
and wind up in a timeline where the Foundation
and the GOC had never joined forces.
In this reality, The Foundation was a comparatively
benevolent organization that only sought to
secure, contain, and protect anomalies.
It rarely destroyed anomalous beings unless
those beings posed an existential threat to
other life.
According to the agent I spoke to, if a humanoid
anomaly like me were to be contained by this
version of the organization, I’d most likely
be given free room and board and three meals
a day.
Even if freedom was my ultimate goal, I couldn’t
say that life didn’t tempt me.
I agreed to help this Foundation agent find
the rest of their team, as long as they were
telling the truth.
Day 54-67.
The mobile task force agent and I worked together
to search the facility for other Foundation
personnel - not ones on the payroll of Site-13,
I should clarify.
It was nice having someone to talk to, even
if they recoiled in fear when I mentioned
my best friend was a clown.
I guess a lot of people in this dimension
have an irrational fear of clowns.
By the way, my new friend said that their
name was Agent Ben Mcdowell, and apparently
Site-13 was the most dangerous site that their
task force had ever been deployed into.
I couldn’t say that I wasn’t honored,
especially after all this place had put me
through.
But the nightmare was far from over because
on Day 68…
Oh god, Day 68.
… the leeches surrounded us and were out
for blood.
Agent Mcdowell had only limited ammunition,
and I was still incredibly hesitant to use
my powers on other anomalies.
Of course, my resolve was about to get pushed
to its breaking point as an enormous mutated
leech arrived at our location.
It was biggest anomaly I’d ever seen and
yet there was something uncannily familiar
about it.
Elijah?
Could it be?
The super leech lashed out at Agent McDowell
with its huge tentacles and pulled them into
its terrible toothy mouth.
I ran away as fast as I could.
Should I have felt bad that I had left my
new ally behind with a giant monstrous anomaly?
Yes, I was only human after all.
But self-preservation had kicked in at the
time, and my mind hadn’t fully accepted
that I should be protecting someone dressed
in a Foundation uniform over another anomaly.
Sorry, Agent Mcdowell.
At the very least, I won’t forget your kindness.
Day 69-84.
I was on my own again, wandering through the
facility as it twisted and changed.
Trapped in a dimension that wasn’t my own,
with freedom feeling even less possible now
that I knew there was an entirely different
Foundation after me now.
I never saw Elijah again - or rather, the
horrific thing that Elijah had become.
I made a guess, grimly, that Dr. Hadley was
probably gone by now.
So many lives had been lost because of the
cruelty of Site Director Eliott Emerson.
If I found him, I would make sure that he
paid for the hell he put us through.
Day 85.
On Day 85, I did find him.
There he was, screaming as he was pulled along
the wheel-like face of a terrifying many-armed
god.
I couldn’t stare too long because the wheel
was covered in runes that were cognitohazards,
but I got a good enough look.
The man responsible for all of this was now
being tormented himself.
I wouldn’t have been capable of a better
punishment on my own, so I left him to his
fate.
Day 86-100
It took me fifteen more days of searching
for staircases before I made it to the rooftop
of site-13.
When I got there, a Foundation helicopter
was waiting for me.
And fortunately, it was the foundation of
this new dimension.
One that would provide food and shelter for
me like a human deserves and never subject
me to experiments against my will.
As I watched Site-13 get farther away from
inside the helicopter, a smile crossed my
face for the first time in 100 days.
Now go check out “I Survived 100 Days in
SCP-3008...
Here's What Happened” and “I Survived
100 Days of SCP-001 When Day Breaks...
Here's What Happened” for more crazy 100
days challenges!